all right Oh jackpot on back it's
impossible to play like ready
my mic dropping okay so we're gonna try
and break this the table ting smash we
found out a new instruments give me a
demonstration scream son anymore
Oh God
okay I think you have got the touch now
yeah that was pathetic
don't get so guys leave a comment on
where you when I can make a new strip I
will be little will live maybe I'll
start using this server yeah stop
spinning
breath or a little or roughly like that
creative video shooting and today we'll
be playing with musical instruments
let's go let's go didn't see you that
[Applause]
not-so-friendly pass
I should have catch that I'm sorry I
can't bleep you garden back okay so I've
shaved my head off head off do we have
any rules
the first rule there is no okay this is
this is why you have rules and tables
[Applause]
instead they're oh good one good one
no more midday tomorrow
guten tag to infinity divorcing yeah yes
that was that was interesting ah it
didn't do the chain reaction we were
hoping oh four one two three four best
so far what's up everybody
what are you doing come on focus I've
been doing this for like what's up guys
weapon can see we've kiss so we know
where it's kind of begin again click on
begin become
okay so let's try five our Antonette
with the edge of the table
with the racket okay so let's write five
around an inch I give up
and what's up previous videos there I'm
doing
I know what it always carries on leave
me to fend off
they just keep dropping I've been
working on my new serve because they
endlessly hit there get done with her
baby come on man
what's Berta it's time for the interim I
went far they know it's time for y'all
ah ultra now with it is so messed up
yeah of course mm there you go there you
go
next time next time it's time for you to
do it yourself so you start learning how
to do it plus plus
let's write this out is it visible you
might not even okay I like the sound
let's ride these outs so it's good note
maybe I should always have yeah so but
it hurts it hurts a lot
yeah amazing thanks for helping us reach
100 million
[Music]